[Music]
Spirit however has shown itself to us to
be neither merely the withdrawal of
self-consciousness into its pure
inwardness nor the mere submergence of
self-consciousness into sub and the
nonbeing of its moment of difference but
spirit is this movement of the self
which empties itself of itself and sinks
into its substance and also as subject
has gone out of that substance into
itself making the substance into an
object and a Content at the same time as
it cancels this difference between
objectivity and content that first
reflection out of immediacy is the
subject's differentiation of itself from
its substance or the Notions separation
of itself from itself the withdrawal
into itself and the becoming of the pure
eye since this difference is the pure
Act of I equals I the notion is the
necessity and the uprising of existence
which has substance for its Essence and
subsists on its own
account but this subsistence of
existence
on its own account is the notion posited
IND
determinedness and is thus also its
imminent movement that of going down
into the simple substance which is
subject only as this negativity and
movement the eye has neither to cling to
itself in the form of self-consciousness
as against the form of substantiality
and objectivity as if it were afraid of
the externalization of itself the power
of spirit lies rather in remaining the
self-same spirit in its externalization
and as that which is both in itself and
for itself and making its being for
itself no less merely a moment than it's
in itself nor is Spirit of terium quid
that casts the differences back into the
abyss of the absolute and declares that
they in they are all the same on the
contrary knowing is the seeming
inactivity which merely contemplates how
what is differentiated spontaneously
moves in its own self and returns into
its
Unity paragraph
84 is a little bit shorter than the
massive paragraph 803 that just came
before it but there's a lot going on
there and as we're approaching the end
of absolute knowing we're really
grappling with a central question that
this one is posing for us raising uh
getting us to ask what is it or how is
it that Spirit
knows what it knows in absolute knowing
we should think you know well what is
absolute knowing and I do want to point
out something that Echoes the par RH
right before which I didn't talk about
quite as much in that because there was
so much to go over towards the end he's
going to say spirit is not a titium quit
a third right that casts the differences
and differences is an important term
here that we'll come back to in a moment
back into the abyss the op right of the
absolute and and so we saw that
formulation just earlier in the previous
paragraph um why talk about an abyss so
what is an abyss an abyss and this is
very nicely built into the German term
here up right so grund is a foundation
then up is is from away from right and
it's something that doesn't have a
foundation something that opens up a ASM
before you you know like in old movies
where they would take like a rock or
something and drop it and then listen do
I hear it hit the ground and they would
after a while come back up and say I I
didn't hear anything right so you can't
find a basis you can't find a ground and
this notion of
Abyss it's where things that are are too
let's say too vague too
underdeveloped go and
disappear if we're talking about the
absolute so the question here is well
how do we approach the absolute
something that Hegel is you know
evidently very interested in and I think
readers of Hegel both then and now are
also quite interested in and when we
think about the absolute we're thinking
about like what what in compes
everything so if the absolute itself
were to
be an abyss well then we've got problems
there and there's really you know two
different ways that come to mind where
the absolute could be an
abyss one of them is you know the sort
of
vague talk about the absolute that we
see in other people of the time and
Hegel doesn't really like this Hegel
thinks that that is you know to go back
to Something in the preface a night when
all cows are black you don't learn
anything there's no knowing going on
there knowing this in has to be
something that is at the same time
differentiated and
unified it can't just be some mystical
experience of the absolute or something
like that there's another way in which
the absolute could also be an Upland and
an abyss right and that would be if
there really isn't any absolute if it's
all just you know perception or
perspective if if we're going to like
Veer off into something that we
typically later on will call neoism now
that's a term that's actually around in
hegel's time but not being used very
much interestingly yabe who who is a
person that we think is you know the
first uh author to use it is targeting
the idealistic philosophy particularly
that of Kant and um you know maybe this
carries through to Hegel we could ask
this very important question that Hegel
thinks he's got answered you know if we
don't have some sort of epistemological
closure point in absolute knowing does
it all fall apart now personally I don't
think it does I I don't think that Hegel
uh managed to bring off the project that
he was trying to do obviously history
didn't end with uh Hegel publishing the
phenomenology of spirit right uh there's
plenty to go on after that but he seemed
to think that that was quite important
we we talked about this in the preface
right all right so that's all kind of
preceding matters and I did bring up
this uh issue of uh
differences so there's a lot of terms
here
differentiating that are getting uh
brought up here and um unid is the uh
key term in German you know meaning to
separate things off from each other to
distinguish them to to differentiate
works just well difference uned um so
you know keep that in mind as we're
going through this as well all right so
coming back to the beginning of it he
tells us Spirit now notice this he's not
saying Spirit isn't this isn't this but
is this he's saying it's not just this
not just this but also this Spirit has
shown itself to us the phenomenologists
the people carrying this out Hegel and
us his readers to be neither merely so
it's not just
the
withdrawal uh of
self-consciousness into pure inwardness
inite right um so it's not just
self-consciousness we could say
retreating or pulling itself I like that
with a z in right pulling itself back
into its pure interiority so it's it but
it is also that that is happening that's
part of the the story here nor is it
simply the submergence the F zenong and
hegel's going to use this word you know
zinin here to to fall into to to settle
into to sink into uh of
self-consciousness once again actually
it's there's Ela uh he doesn't say
self-consciousness twice into substance
and here he says something really
interesting again this ties in with the
up the abyss thing nor the mere
submergence of self-consciousness into
substance
and the
nonbeing of its moment of difference now
the nonbeing here is
not um you know just a
negation of being
Z
right it's actually Nick Z
so you know we could translate this as
non-being but I mean more literally it's
the nothingness of being or being
nothingness ni is
nothing so um submergence into substance
there's a kind of nothingness involved
in uh this difference that is taking
place and we're going to look at that in
just a moment then he goes on and he
says but spirit is this
movement of the self right so the zst
and uh once again as I've pointed out so
many times the four s's Spirit self
substance and subject how are these
related to each other how are these
connected to each other well I mean here
we actually do get the answer they're
all
Spirit right every one one of them
figures into what spirit is and
therefore what an absolute knowing it is
knowing which is in part A knowing of
its own self the self that is Spirit but
also knowing
ourselves as the selves that we are as
and I hesitate to use this word part but
we could say this parts or components or
moments is another term that Hegel often
uses of spirit as self-c consciousnesses
right okay so let's let's look more
closely at what this is uh the movement
the beong of the self and what is the
self doing it empties itself well yeah
externalizes itself and oyer right it
goes outside of itself is that emptying
itself sure by implication because if
you're taking something out of one
container over here and moving it
somewhere else like you know you get a
package of hot dogs because you're going
to go to make yourself some hot dogs and
you open it up and you know if it's
Oscar meire there's five hot dogs in in
there and you you you know undo the
thing and you take them out you put them
on the plate because you're going to
heat them up maybe you're going to you
know boil them or put them in the
microwave okay now that what was in that
container
is no longer in there right you've
endered it you've you've externalized it
from that okay so I mean this is a very
spatial metaphor but it it works and
self is emptying itself into substance
and we saw this interplay between
substance and subject being really
highlighted in the previous paragraph
and you know it's going to be implicit
in the paragraphs yet to come but here's
where they're being brought together in
an incredibly unified way all right so
um empties itself of itself and sinks
notice again uh
submergence uh into its substance
but also as subject so the self
is
substance every self is a
substance but it's also
subject and you know if if if the self
or merely substance then it couldn't
really be a self it has to also be
subject capable of
agency capable of taking a position on
itself right being something that is for
itself as as he's going to bring up a
little bit later
on so as subject it has gone out of that
substance into itself and now here we
get the relation in the self between
subject and substance what is it well on
the side of
substance substance can be grasped here
in two ways and at first you might say
well these are the same thing right
hegel's just engaging in a little bit of
rhetoric where he says the same thing
basically twice but that's not what's
going on as we follow through right
making the substance into an object gig
andand and a content an
inhalt okay substance could be gag
andand that is something that is there
for the self that is there for the
subject present in a you know objective
way we could say but it's also content
content of what content of the knowing
the thinking the behavior the Hond right
of the self there's both a theoretical
and practical side to this absolute
knowing is not a pure abstract
theoretical knowing it is an
all-encompassing knowing that Embraces
both the theoretical and the
Practical Hegel goes on in the next
sentence and he tells
us that
uh it makes the substance into object
and content at the same time as it
cancels now that's alh right it alhed
this
difference uh right between objectivity
gag and stend kite and content inhal now
is there an important difference here
between object
gagan and um you know objectivity gagin
Stanley kite I I don't think so maybe we
could explore this more but I I tend to
think that there he is actually just
talking about being you know being in
the mode of an object and being in the
mode of content and there is a
distinction between them um but at the
same time that distinction or that
difference is being cancelled annuled or
perhaps brought to a higher level
right so he says that first reflection
out of immediacy on Mite right so notice
that that he's using uh reflexion again
as he did in the previous paragraph very
important there's a reflecting oneself
you know unfolding oneself into multi
multiples
um uh out
of um immediacy
on right so uh no longer is it purely
immediate
unmediated is the subject's
differentiation of itself from its
substance so this you know we've got uh
self subject substance all connected
together and the subject is being you
know not just separated but we could
even say estranged from its substance uh
as we saw in the previous paragraph a
big important thing to be worked through
and now hegle brings up the the notion
or the concept the
Griff which the entire phenomenology has
been about exploring Spirit comes to be
understood and known in its Fuller
workings in its development it's you
know uh unfolding it's bringing to a
fruition in the concept the fully
developed
concept um in a conceptual way which
means the self not just relates itself
to substance but uh also understands
itself through substance as a substance
that is at the same time a subject all
right so let let's go on with this so
the Notions separation of itself from
itself there there's actually uh three
different things that are being
mentioned here separation of itself from
itself
um not exactly what hegel's saying here
but not totally wrong Zeke and Zenda
so Zeke applying to itself right this is
a reflexive verb um and
z z too and the an SEP separating itself
out into two uh you know separating
itself from itself yes that works
separating itself into two bifurcating
itself we might even say um so that's
one thing that's going on then we have
with draw into itself and this is not
you
know this is actually a term that we saw
come up in the religion section quite a
bit in zek gain going into it self now
they both wind up in the same place
inside the self right in the self's
interiority but
they're different Locs we could say so
let's not mix them up
completely and then what else do we have
he says the becoming of the pure eye the
becoming the
veren of
this right and the
ey the eye that equals eye that we've
been talking about quite a bit in the
previous paragraphs and this has come up
before in other sections as well um
notice that this equal sign you know if
it's Gite as we talked about before
doesn't always mean is identical with
right or can be interchanged with
without any loss or addition of
meaning it's a little bit broader than
that there's a correspondence between
the eye and the eye which are both the
same eye but are also you
know separated off from each other right
andine right so they've been uh
distanced to some degree but they've
also been brought together so he says
that since this difference is the pure
act taught right the DU
of I equals I I equals I does something
or is what is done here's where he says
something really interesting the notion
the concept is the necessity the note
vendite now remember back to the
previous paragraph We had a concern that
maybe we're not actually grasping things
in their necessity but in Pure
accidentality or contingency that we're
not getting at the heart of of the
matter um Hegel is saying here that the
notion is the
necessity and then it goes the
uprising the you know coming into to to
being we could say of
existence of
dine coming
into the world into reality into
Vite to go backwards to the previous
paragraph something that that got
brought up and then didn't get
elaborated more
fully actual history right
actual
continuity and causal connections and
contingency and necessity brought
together so um you know the concept at
this point is providing existence with
this and he says uh which has substance
for its
right and subsist now subsist and
substance there's a temptation to link
them together because they look very
close in English but it's uh
bishan uh as
subsistence um you know another mode of
being we could say um has substance for
its Essence subsists on its own account
this subsistence of essence on its own
account is what something pure substance
left by itself no it
is uh the
notion posited in determinateness given
btim now the notion we could think of
how how does a notion take on
determinateness
well uh part of it is by
unpacking what is distinctive to it
what's what makes a difference than
other
Notions at other points in time or
development but we can also think about
the
subject that is grasping conceptually
substance different
modes
of understanding of grasping of Desiring
of willing of moving
towards well these are ways of
introducing determinateness as well
right
uh of determining
bem these matters so this is a very rich
uh idea that's being worked out here
actually just referenced by Hegel not
really worked out so posited
indeterminateness heus says it's thus
also its
imminent movement that of going down
into the simple substance which is
subject only as this negativity and
movement here's where get to once again
we could say the substance is in itself
what is the in itself the in itself in
general is that which has being that
which is there for the uh subject the
self the
self-consciousness um but doesn't have a
lot of agency or you know
intensive uh self- relation the way that
the self and the subject do this the
subject is for itself right it is a
negativity of subst
substance is not the total story now
things get more complicated because the
self and the subject are also substances
but they're substances that are
different than others by being for
itself I mean here in this paragraph you
can see that Hegel um although you know
he uses for itself and in itself and
some other locutions in ways that you
can't always pin down and say it's
always this this is very close to what
sard is saying in uh being in
nothingness isn't it
about the in itself and for itself all
right side sideline side note uh noted
let's let's move back to this so um
subject only has this negativity and
movement then he says the eye has
neither to cling to itself in the form
of self-consciousness as against the
form of substantiality and objectivity
as if it were afraid of the
externalization of itself there's a
sense in which you know if you are
externalizing yourself you become
vulnerable to all the other things
within the world that's why there's a
temptation to you know Retreat to Pure
inwardness or to allow yourself to sink
into a substance that doesn't have to
think about
itself
um but at this point the self doesn't
have to have that anxiety or fear or
aversion right it can actually be
optimistic and
hopeful doesn't have to cling to itself
in the form of
self-consciousness it can be
self-consciousness and at the same time
not just
self-consciousness uh against the form
of substantiality being substance and
objectivity gag and stanite once again
um so he says here something very
important the power of spirit lies
rather in remaining the the self-same
spirit in its
externalization and as that which is
both in itself and for itself in making
its being for self no less merely a
moment than it's in itself so instead of
prioritizing the for itself and saying
this is where my self-consciousness
really lies but I have to by virtue of
belonging to a world to culture uh of
acting I have to externalize myself into
substance and I lose something of myself
in there Hegel is saying if we properly
understand ourselves and others as well
as spirit this at this point is not
going to be the problem that we're
making it out to be because both the in
itself and the for itself are
moments neither of them have absolute
priority within the absolute that we are
already within and now mapping out
trying to understand trying to wrap our
head around conceptually for ourselves
so we have the kind of knowledge that
Spirit has not just the knowledge that a
individual
self-consciousness has so it Remains the
selfsame spirit
right here's where he says nor is Spirit
a ter quit uh third literally uh you
know that casts the differences back
into the abyss of the absolute and
declares that they're in they're all the
same it wants to retain these
differences these distinctions these
separating things out and yet keep them
United and this is what conceptual
thinking thinking through the concept is
able to do for us that's why we have to
have moved Beyond mere representation
forong that we saw so elaborated in the
religion section and we need to move
Beyond inadequate philosophical points
of view philosophies of the
understanding as Hegel will later call
them that are not conceptual but are
also working with
representations and think in terms of
Concepts and the
concepts so
no you know casting everything into some
sort of well it's all the same man it's
all one none of that stuff for Hegel yes
in in some sense Hegel is a mon it is
all one Spirit right but spirit is
differentiated very much so richly
variegated it has to be understood in
this richness and complexity and dynamic
connections of these moments to each
other so he says on the
contrary knowing is this seeming not
actual seeming inac ity which merely
contemplates merely looks on how what is
differentiated spontaneously moves in
its own self and returns into its Unity
now is it really that way no things are
actually much
more subjectively
intense in this way spirit
is all of this right through
self-conscious ious individual
self-consciousness is the kind of
self-consciousness that's reading
hegel's phenomenology right now and
thinking about this paragraph or
explaining this paragraph to you all of
this is you know something that we could
think about as inactivity not doing
something but there is some doing
something going on here in the
contemplation in understanding these
things in knowing as just just to bring
this to a close we could say that visen
knowing is an active term for Hegel it's
not like we have well here's the sphere
of
action practice you know the real world
over here and then we have the
idealistic world of contemplating our
Notions over here no no no they
interpenetrate each other knowing things
in the world knowing the world knowing
ourselves knowing others knowing history
all of these
knowings that are being rolled into
absolute knowing are
activities of the
subject can they be turned into
substance yes and no we'll we'll see how
that works as we move on through but you
see that there's a lot of stuff being
worked out and set out for us to work
through through in this relatively short
paragraph uh